une question pascal qu'est ce qu'elle
propose vraiment l laeticia hallyday là
dans la négociation n'a pour l'instant
je ne sais pas du tout parce que ça ne
filtre pas non pas du tout mais ça file
trois pas pour le lait ce qui est dit là
même que que que laura smet voudrait
elle la maison de marnes-la-coquette qui
seraient entre 7 et 15 millions d'euros
30 millions s'est passé ce que j'ai lu
dans la presse comme vous je sais j'en
sais pas plus vous sais pas si c'est sûr
d'accord et david quelques david lui
serait plus intéressé sur les droits
moraux de 21 euros 24 albums lesquels on
se parle tout ça pour l'instant est très
flou maintenant il ya eu effectivement
durant l'été des négociations ça on en
est sûr mais il ya eu un rapprochement
entre avocats ça c'est évident
maintenant est-ce que ça va aboutir
est ce qu'il va pas y avoir un grain de
sable à un moment donné c'est tout à
fait possible parce qu'il ya des ego
aussi qu'ils sont surdimensionnés dans
cette affaire depuis le début donc si
vous voulez moi je peux pas répondre là
à cette question et sébastien vous avez
des infos sur le traitement d'année
govou non pas sur le traitement
exactement mais il y avait des
négociations qui apparemment avaient
commencé d'ailleurs on avait vu des
photos de laura sortant de la savannah
mais justement suite à ses photos et ses
informations qui ont en gros fuite et
parce que ça devait rester
confidentielle là on peut penser que ça
ont pu un peu les choses la négociation
pour le moment moi j'ai lu effectivement
qu'en fait les avocats de laëtitia
reprocherait à laura smet d'avoir fait
fuiter exactement soit larbi donc les
photos qui sont sortis chez myriam alors
bien la semaine dernière l'émission de
comprendre bien sûr je décrypte là je ne
juge pas content tu en deviens donc les
photos qui sortent chez vous on se
serait dans l'entourage de laura smet
pas l'entourage leur aspen que vous
auriez eu là dessus je n'ai vraiment à
ça veut dire oui catherine je crois vous
avez eu des avocats vous moi c'est à
dire ce qu'est un jeu de manipulation
très fort là dedans je peux pas tout
dire non plus bien lui mettre une
pression en étant fautif otunnu on
aurait pu penser au groupe dans ses
images de laura entrant dans la villa
johnny aurait pu être au départ
téléguidé par l'entourage de laetitia
pour se donner bonne contre une bonne
image d'elle même en effet c'est faux en
effet ces fausses informations
mariam sont bonnes c'est que ça vient ça
vient pas de l'entourage de laetitia
après il ya deux choses
mais pardon juste que je garde que je
comprenne qu est ce qu elle gagne
affaire sale race parce que qu'est ce
qu'elles gagnent à faire ça de faire
fuiter le fait qu'elle était la marque
wasquehal
cas de laura vous les croyez que la
négociation à l'essai avant la sortie de
l'album le 19 octobre ils voulaient
précipiter un petit peu les négociations
en disant laetitia veut pouvoir parler
librement et dire ça y est c'est fait et
c'est ils se sont trompés parce qu'en
fait elle veut bien par elle veut
négocier oui elle va sûrement le faire
mais d'ici le 30 novembre pour le
prochain procès est donc et et donc ils
sont dit si on commence à faire fuiter
qu'elle va donner la maison qu'elle va
donner un peu des pourcentages et c'est
très compliqué pour elle de ce drôle de
dire bah non finalement je fais pas et
du coup elle est l effet contraire parce
que du coup les avocats laetitia sur
cette donnée en effet que ce qu'on
possède est la négociation il porte sur
les biens français
ce qu'on oublie c'est le fisc est énorme
dette d'office et c est ce que les
enfants au dollar reprend des dettes du
fisc ou passer en force en les
réconciliant piégé ils sont piégés parce
que de toute façon dans la sphère c'est
laeticia qui gagnera puisque
financièrement qui sont ces gestes qui
s'adresse à acheter une promotion très
tranquille oui benoît tranquille
laetitia si tu nous écoutes donne un peu
de blé devrait surtout ton avis sur sur
la communication la stratégie mais j'ai
un mot parce que moi je sais pas si vous
le saviez mais moi je n'ai appris cette
semaine en lisant et j'aimerais vous
m'expliquer ce qu'est pascal en fait ce
qu'on a appris aussi cette semaine c'est
que en réalité johnny hallyday a
déshérité
laura et david mais également en fait
jade et joy
c'est ça puisque en fait c'est pas tout
à fait ça sert tout à fait ça mais non
c'est pas ça
c'est à dire aller sonner trust y sont
elles sont déshérités alors qu elles
constatent elles sont mineures pour
l'instant donc elles ne peuvent pas
s'occuper de quoi que ce soit pour
l'instant donc c'est uniquement laetitia
qui le gère pour l'instant qui hérite de
tout qui arrive que la majorité des
enfants qui hériterait de tous jusqu'à
la majorité des enfants sachant que dans
le 3,6 à quelqu'un qui est au dessus qui
chapote et letizia ne peut rien ça veut
pas ça veut quand même dire que si
laeticia avant la majorité d'exemple à
une chèvre actions symboliques ou sur
marie elle peut donc enlever beaucoup
d'argent à ses enfants
absolument musulmans alors être ce n'est
pas un héritage non c'est une boîte dans
lequel on met des sous et l'adsl qui
détient l'autre us même si un
gestionnaire mais c'est sans elle c'est
gestionnaire qui sont exceptionnelles
qu'a tout c'est le gestionnaire qui sont
occupés ça elle ne peut rien c'est
décevant mais je veux pas pinailler mais
c'est je regrette c'est des points
juridiques
elle ne peut
même question à cet héritage c'est un
cadeau empoisonné ou un cadeau on hérite
du passif ou c'est quoi cet âge c'est
tout l'enjeu daniel en france j'ai fait
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est un
gars vrai cadeau empoisonné
il savait oui l'argent et aux états unis
le fait savoir en quoi ça nous intéresse
dans cette histoire c'est parce que ya
dans toutes les familles des problèmes
d'héritage évidemment pas avec cet
argent là mais ouais je sais qu'il ya
des gens qui ont hérité de maison à
l'île de règles par exemple qu'ils ont
été obligés rose est pas pour amener à
des choses qu'on peut être au début il
ya des gens qui ont été à parce que la
maison avait été pas pris tellement de
valeur et ça donc
donc voilà c'est une histoire comme ça
qu'il a cessé de faire du jeu
proportionnée c'est aux états et donc
c'est des choses qui peuvent arriver à
tout le monde c'est un vrai cadeau et
alors ça au delà des trusts en effet tu
as tu as tu as raison l'enjeu il est
différent pour les deux enfants laura
aurait besoin présentement des besoins
financiers là où david revendique le
droit moraux de la gestion de la fpt de
son père ce qui a toujours entendu
d'accord la presse people la sincérité
aussi de communication quand elle arrive
là à l'aéroport et qu'on voit qu'elle
arrive avec les cheveux blonds comme et
john ils ont quand même eu johnny
lacroix deux derniers viennent bien de
johnny qu'est-ce qu'elle vient chercher
l'amour du public français elle vient
chercher là comme c'est qu'il va y avoir
des photos ap donc vous étiez dans
l'orgie de ben non mais de toute manière
c'est normal qu est ce qu elle s'habille
bien que les images ça que vous nous
avez donné d'ailleurs pas beaucoup
pardon un groupe qu'on nous a donné les
images de son arrivée je crois que
devant un célèbre hôtel parisien on la
voit voilà on la voit ça c'est les
images totalement exclusifs pour décoder
paparazzi nous ont donné voilà où elle
voit voilà j'ai la même grille et
regarder tous les paparazzis qui a on
voit en plus à tout petit peu sébastien
farran voilà le manager que juste sur la
côte est et tous les paparazzis qui sont
là voilà ça c'est quoi ces c'est comme à
mort non alors ça elle ne contrôle pas à
partir du moment où elle a posé le pied
à l'aéroport l'autre jour et jusqu'au
moment où un parti rival ailleurs 15
personnes derrière elle mais elle sait
qu'elle va être photographiés donc frv
guillaume joli bas le problème c'est que
elle pendant toute sa communication
qu'on va avoir on va tous est
extrêmement déçu parce qu'elle va donner
trois interviews donc à la télévision à
presse écrite à la radio de ça
et qu elle va ne vaut elle ne va vouloir
ne parlait que de johnny on a fait cet
album comme ça que les deux seules
choses quand on veut savoir c'est est ce
que est ce que tu vas rendre l'argent ou
de ou pas est ce que tu veux dire
j'étais là parce que c'est le seul qui
parle d'une erreur de 800000 euros pour
le disque qui va sortir ça c'est l'arrêt
là dessus c'est confirmé c'est confirmé
huit cent mille euros
moi ce qui m'étonne c'est pas toujours
vécu comme ça je vais toujours avec des
avants sein d'accor donc c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau